by breaking right now new report just
came out Washington Post federal
prosecutors have now interviewed James
Comey as they now weigh whether or not
to charge his former deputy FBI director
Andrew McCabe with a crime for his
obsessive lying which is why he was
reportedly now fired it looks like two
key members of the deep state yeah
they're now turning on each other and
this could be the signs of the wall
collapsing so yzma cave and others now
finally going to be exposed about their
constant extreme wrongdoing I've said
many times on this show starting in
January this is the year of the
boomerang we'll give you all the
breaking developments and also tonight
according to reports the disgraced
former deputy FBI director McCabe who as
we said was fired because of his pattern
of blatant lying
he wrote a personal confidential memo
detailing his so-called concerns over
the president's decision to fire his
former boss and personal friend
McCabe reportedly turned that memo over
to there you see it Robert Muller's team
of witch hunters the so called
investigators Democratic donors Hillary
supporters to help their efforts and as
you can imagine the Trump hating press
and their friends in the left they were
very excited very wrong as I'll explain
in a second but very excited take a look
now we find out that the president
wanted to fire coming on the grounds
that he want he was concerned about the
aggressive Russian and probe in other
words he did it to protect himself to
obstruct justice this is clearly clearly
it seems to me
close to the smoking gun of obstruction
we have enough information about this
president and his attempts to control
Rosenstein and jeff sessions and to
literally have them protect him from
this investigation I think it is clear
that he's obstructed justice the
question about the President and commis
firing has always been what did it mean
about the Russian investors one of the
people that Donald Trump has been
hammering you know that he doesn't trust
them and all of a sudden signed put it
really did try to give him cover a cover
story to fire truck
call me wonder why I mean talk about
repaying a favor
I'm just saying that's that's pretty
amazing how this is all turning out
pretty amazing how dumb my so-called
colleagues in this industry are you know
what it's not a real news story more
lives more in serie Moore breathless
reporting of so-called news and while
McCabe expressed concerns about Trump
using a cover story to fire Comey
okay here's what they're not telling you
the president had the full authority to
fire Comey for any reason he didn't need
a cover story at all remember even Comey
himself said the President had the right
to fire him for any reason that's fake
news that's hysteria
that's outright lying to you the
American people now this comes after our
own Adam Housley reported that McCabe
allegedly threatened to take others down
with him if he was fired get it they're
now turning on each other now in reality
this McCabe memo provides literally no
evidence that the president did anything
wrong instead the memo does reveal
something else according to the document
the Deputy Attorney General rod Rosen
Stein I've been warning you to keep that
name in your head he told McCabe about
conversations he had with the president
surrounding the FBI's Russia
investigation and the firing of Comey
now this means rod Rosenstein again it's
obviously a witness to the special
counsels investigation witness number
one this very investigation he's
overseas he's even more compromised than
we thought tonight so how is it possible
again the Attorney General Jeff Sessions
recused himself over so-called possible
conflicts of interest citing the wrong
law and statute in doing so but rod
Rosenstein he's not conflicted remember
he also signed that final FISA warrant
he put his signature on it then that was
with the bought and paid for Hillary
Clinton dossier Russian propaganda a
foreign agent literally using Russian
lies yeah to lie to you the American
people just one more wrinkle to Muller's
completely flawed fraudulent witch-hunt
it needs to end look at what this is
doing to this country and by the way you
the American people have already paid
more than 16 million dollars to fund
this partisan
for to robert muller and for what 379
days without any evidence of any russia
so-called collusion whatsoever nothing
and also breaking tonight we're peeling
back even more layers of this deep State
John Solomon will join us tonight brand
new information details on serious and
shocking abuse of power you will be here
in moments to preview this upcoming
bombshell report which reveals that in
2016 the Obama administration pressured
the FBI to ramp up their spying
operations against the Trump campaign
and the Trump administration a massive
exclusive stay with us also yesterday in
the Washington Examiner Byron York
highlighted the 2017 congressional
testimony from fusion GPS founder Glenn
Simpson he told members of the Senate
Judiciary Committee that quote the FBI
had a human source inside the Trump
campaign okay that was way back in 2017
don't forget last week former CIA
director turned CNN hack while Director
of National Intelligence James clapper
actually said that Trump should be so
happy that the FBI was spying on his
campaign really oh the United States of
America or Venezuela take a look so I
asked you was the FBI spying on Trump's
campaign oh no they were not they were
spying on a term I don't particularly
like but on what the Russians were doing
trying to understand were the Russians
infiltrating trying to gain access
trying to gain leverage and influence
what they do so why doesn't he like that
he should be happy that should be why
didn't you go to him in the spring of
2016 and say hey there's this guy that
you never met that we're watching he
would have helped you remember the most
extol pataw riordan sin the Comey memo
was I didn't do this but if anyone
around me did I want the world to know
so it's crystal clear that the Trump
campaign yes was spied on was monitored
was closely observed by the deep state
which was hell-bent on making sure
Donald Trump never became the president
a major abuse of power it's all
unraveling now meanwhile clapper who you
just heard from he's now actually in a
really twisted distorted way blaming
Republicans for obstructing federal
efforts to
warned the American people about the
Russian election and appearance in 2016
remember the núñez Washington Examiner
piece 2014 he warned us way ahead of you
take a look
there was concern on the part of the
President himself because of the
allegations of rigging which the
candidate Trump was then espousing that
anything that the President did would be
viewed as political and he would be
putting his hand on the scale and favor
one candidate to the disfavor of the
other so I think Ben's exactly right and
my book comports with his account and he
says but not for Mitch McConnell the
Senate Majority Leader perhaps there
would have been more said did Mitch
McConnell stand in the way well the
Republicans in general did we encounter
reluctance on their part to enter into a
very aggressive statement about the
Russian do Republicans really mr.
clapper known liar maybe clapper should
read this 2016 report from NBC News they
titled it why didn't Obama do more about
Russian election hacking according to
NBC News the Obama administration didn't
act because quote they thought that
Hillary Clinton was going to win
and a potential cyber war with Russia
just wasn't worth it looks like clapper
is righty-right fitting right there in
at CNN fake news he gets paid and of
course while clapper everyone else in
the deep state tries to drag this
president down the president has been up
to serious business to actually attend
to on the world stage you know important
things like peace the upcoming talks
with the North Korean dictator a little
Rocket Man Kim jong-un well last night
the Secretary of State Mike Pompeo held
a productive meeting with a high-ranking
member of the North Korean regime first
time in 18 years on US soil and this is
what Pompeo had to say earlier today
today Vice Chairman Kim and I discussed
our countries could come together and
take advantage of the unique opportunity
that our two leaders have created
through their visions of the future that
they have so clearly articulated the
proposed summit offers a historic
opening for President Trump and Chairman
Kim to boldly the United States and the
DPRK into a new era of peace prosperity
and security
our two countries face a pivotal moment
in our relationship in which it could be
nothing short of tragic to let this
opportunity go to waste so that if Kim
jong-un denuclearize as there is a
brighter path for North Korea who
envisioned a strong connected and secure
prosperous North Korea that maintains
its cultural heritage but it's
integrated into the community of nations
great news the president himself he's
set to meet with this high-ranking North
Korean official tomorrow and by the way
that Korean official will be delivering
a letter from Kim jong-un himself
take a look he were doing very well with
North Korea our Secretary of State has
had very good meetings he's meeting
again today I believe they'll be coming
down to Washington on Friday and a
letter is going to be delivered to me
from Kim Jong onin so I look forward to
seeing what's in the letter
hopefully we'll have a meeting on the
12th that's going along very well but I
want it to be meaningful it doesn't mean
it gets all done at one meeting maybe
you have to have a second or a third and
maybe we'll have none but it's in good
hands as the president manages the
ongoing negotiations with North Korea
while he's also been making waves right
here at home and I think good waves
today the president pardon friend of
this program conservative activist
author Dinesh D'Souza remember he was
prosecuted under the Obama
administration for violating a campaign
finance law one that has rarely ever
punished like this president Trump is
also he is considering a pardon for
Martha Stewart and even for the
Democratic governor former Democratic
governor of Illinois Rod Blagojevich and
while the media barely yawned over
Obama's pardons and Clinton's infamous
pardons they were absolutely spinning
out of control because the president is
using his absolute power of the pardon
he has the right to do whatever he wants
on this too bad
take a look raise questions of whether
the president is sending a message with
these pardons sending a message to
people like Paul Manafort
Michael Flynn those are the obvious
questions that are going to come about
here
he's throwing raw meat a bone to the far
right here dinesh d'souza for over three
decades
has been an extreme peddler of extends
far right ideology and you have to say
hatred president Trump's seemingly
passing out pardons to heroes of the
far-right almost as eagerly as Oprah
once gifted Pontiacs to suburban moms or
one step closer to being a third world
power as of today I mean tariffs and
pardons these are things that we see
from Banana Republic president not only
announced he is pardoning a darling of
the far-right Dinesh D'Souza as you said
mr. Trump added he's also considering
levian c42 stars of his former TV show
making this White House once again seem
detached from reality mark Critch FAL n
clinton drug-dealers obama okay we don't
need lectures from these people leave it
to the media to totally ignore the
massive abuse of power that took place
during the prosecution of say Dinesh
D'Souza memory pled guilty using straw
donors to contribute $20,000 to a
senatorial campaign only after being
threatened with much larger charges
bigger charges from a biased Aunty
conservative prosecutor then let's take
the case of Martha Stewart members she
was found guilty of obstruction of
justice after prosecutors tried and
failed to send her to prison for on an
insider trading charge after well in
other words she had a stock transaction
they couldn't get her on that so they
went after her for obstruction
and don't forget scooter libby the
public servant who had the book thrown
at him over an alleged unproven leak
when they knew who the leaker was the
first day the patrick fitzgerald took
over the case these strong-arm tactics
to elicit guilty convictions from
individuals perhaps who otherwise would
never have been charged cuz they can't
get them on the charge that are
investigating it deserves a serious
conversation in this country and not
coordinated outraged by the hypocritical
double standard in the Trump ad media
and let's just compare all of this to
James Comey
and Peter struck at least a page and
Andrew McCabe and of course the tarmac
meeting with Loretta Lynch and Bill
Clinton remember they cleared Hillary
Clinton of wrongdoing she deleted 33,000
subpoenaed emails classified top secret
special access program information again
subpoenaed on a private server
she covered it up obstructed justice by
deleting him right there and then of
course the acid wash and then of course
the breaking up of the devices with
hammers really I say free Martha Stewart
give her the pardon and compared to
former Clinton national security adviser
remember of Sandy the burglar burger
he stole classified documents from the
National Archives he stuck them in his
pants and in his socks he never got
charged with a crime can you say a
two-tier justice system what happened to
equal justice under the law what
happened to equal application of the law
what happened to our constitutional
rights that we're all equal in this
country
finally tonight a story from a so called
comedian named Samantha be those annoyed
B had to say about Ivanka Trump
it'll make you puke but look anyway it
was on TBS last night Ivanka Trump who
works at the White House chose to post
the second most oblivious tweet we've
seen this week you know Ivanka that's a
beautiful photo of you and your child
but let me just say one mother to
another do something about your dad's
immigration practices you feckless
[Applause]
and tell your father to stop it tell him
that was an Obama thing and see how it
goes okay disgusting right on cue be
revealed just one more blatant example
of what we have discussed on this
program for years if you're a liberal in
the public spotlight you can pretty much
say and do anything else you want and no
consequences and of course the opposite
is true for conservatives we just saw
Roseanne show canceled after the
comments she made but for Samantha be an
apology that's good enough no problem
she said I would like to sincerely
apologize to Ivanka Trump to my viewers
for using an expletive on my show to
describe her last night it was
inappropriate inexcusable TBS shares the
same parent company as fake news CNN
also apologized and then they praised
their late-night so-called star for
doing the same look let me be clear I
don't call for boycotts I don't call for
people to be silenced I don't want
show's canceled I don't want anyone I'm
not calling for anyone in the media to
be fired you think Samantha B is an
untalented none not funny bitter
partisan mindless hack like I do you
have the power turn the channel you
don't have to watch her hateful show
sadly just one more example of what is a
blatant double standard in America
Republicans conservatives sent to the
chopping block and those on the Left
they're given a pass